A MAYBE A LITTLE BIT LATE I WANT
TO START ON THE COMMITTEE NOW --
NOTICING THAT WE HAVE AN ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM -- WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE.
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE OUR FIRST
PRESENTER -- MISTER HILL
[inaudible]
WHAT?
NO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS ON
THIS BILL APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SB -- SIX TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW MAKES IT
LEGAL FOR EIGHT PASSENGERS FOR
PASSENGERS TO SMOKE CANNABIS IN
A PARTY BUS.
LIMO TAXI OR TNC.
AS A RESULT SOME PARTY BUSES AND
LIMO OPERATORS ARE OFFERING
CANNABIS DISPENSARY TOUR IT'S
SIMILAR TO EXISTING TOWARDS FOR
WINERIES OR BROUGH REACH.
MODELED AFTER STATUTES FOR BEER
AND WINE BUSES IN LIMOS SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE WILL PROHIBIT.
CANNABIS USE IN THESE VEHICLES
AND LET'S SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
FOLLOWED.
SPECIFICALLY SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR A PASSENGER
IN A PARTY BUS OR Là M<c.cyan>. TO</c>
SMOKE OR VAPOR CANNABIS AND LESS
THE DRIVER'S COMPARTMENT IS
SEALED OFF SEPARATELY.
AND SET IN SEPARATELY VENTILATED
THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS ANYONE
UNDER TWENTY ONE FROM BEING ON
BOARD IF CANNABIS BALK IS
PRESENT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL.
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE DRIVER IS
NOT IMPAIRED IF CANNABIS SMOKE
IS CONSUMED IN ONE OF THESE FOR
HIGHER VEHICLES.
I WANT TO REINFORCE THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
CANNABIS USE IS ALLOWED IN BUSES
LIMOS AND TAXIS WITHOUT ANY
REGULATION OR CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS THAT'S WHICH IN LAW
TODAY.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE IS NECESSARY
TO CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE AND
APPROPRIATELY REGULATE THESE
BUSINESSES WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
HAD AND HAVE COME UP WITH A SET
OF ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE COMMITTED TO
MAKING THESE AMENDMENTS IN
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION THAT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING.
LIMIT THE BILL COULD JUST BUSES
IN LIMOS.
REQUIRE THAT THESE OPERATORS
MEET ALL REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
FOR CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS
INCLUDING PERMITTING BY THE P.
YOU SEE AN INSPECTIONS BY THE
HIGHWAY PATROL.
REQUIRE A THIRD PARTY LICENSED
ENGINEER TO VERIFY THAT THE
VEHICLES PARTITION EFFECTIVELY
LIMITS THE PASSENGER.
THE PASSAGE OF SMOKE TO THE
DRIVER.
AND ADD RIEN AT ENFORCEMENT
LANGUAGE THAT SUBJECT FOR
OPERATORS TO PENALTIES AND
PERMIT REVOCATION. FOR VIOLATING
THE LAW I FEEL THESE AMENDMENTS
STRIKE A BALANCE THAT ALLOWS FOR
CANNABIS USE ON BUSES IN LIMOS
WHILE PROTECTING THE DRIVER.
PASSENGERS AND CONSUMERS ASKED
OF THE COMMITTEE MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD TODAY AS WE MAKE IT SO
WE CAN MAKE THE NECESSARY
AMENDMENTS IN ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION AND CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES THANK.
MANNER UP JUST FOR SECOND SINCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM I WANT TO STAB
WISH THAT -- MINUTES SECTOR
PLEASE CALL ROLE SANTIAGO HERE
OBERNOLTE.
BUT HOVA [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
SILVER [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
WE ARE FIRST AND SECOND WE HAVE
MAY I MEAN SUPPORT WITNESSES.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
CANNABIS TOURISM IS ON THE RISE
AND REPRESENTS A KEY OPPORTUNITY
FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA IN COLORADO TOURISM
GREW 51% SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND THE STATE LIKE
NEARLY EIGHTEEN MILLION CANNABIS
USE STAYS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ALONE CALIFORNIA'S
FOLLOWING CLOSE BEHIND WITH
CANNABIS TOURIST POPPING UP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SIMPLY PUT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE IS
A STRAIGHT FORWARD BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES APPROPRIATE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS FOR CAMPUS TOURISM
WHILE IMPROVING THE SAFETY OF
BOTH PASSENGERS AND DRIVERS.
MOREOVER CCA STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BEING
TAKEN AND TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREG
COOK REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIPARI.
LIVERY ASSOCIATION THE
REPRESENTATIVE GROUP.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FIVE THOUSAND
THE MISSING OPERATORS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AT THE VERY IMPORTANT
BILL PUBLIC SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY AND WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ALONG THE BENSON HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS COALITION
SUPPORT -- JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE WERE
ORIGINALLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL --
WE SPENT -- THE WEEKEND WORKING
WITH -- SENATOR HILLS --
EXCELLENT STAFF -- THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED.
DO A NUMBER OF THINGS FIRST OF
ALL THEY ASSURE THAT.
THE COMPARTMENTS -- WE'LL HAVE
INTEGRITY SO YOU WON'T HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH -- SECONDHAND
SMOKE -- THERE IS A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS THAT
MIRRORS WHAT IS ALREADY DONE BY
ENGINEERS WITH EMERGENCY EXITS
ON BUSES SO THIS IS PART OF OF
THE CULTURE OF THE INDUSTRY.
AND YOU HAVE C. H. P. OVERSIGHT --
SO WE ARE WITHDRAWING OUR
OPPOSITION WE ARE URGING ARE.
BROTHER AND SISTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLEAGUES TO JOIN
WITH US IN DOING SO.
WE MAY NOT.
IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
[inaudible]
CNN.
MY TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR ON ONE POINT THE THE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
BEING TALKED ABOUT -- ARE NOT IN --
LEDGE FORM THEY WERE WORKED OUT
AT THE TOWARDS LAST MINUTE SO
THEY'RE NOT IN EXCLUDING ELSE'S --
THEY'LL BE TAKEN IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE HAS A RIGHT TO RESERVE
THE TAKE A LOOK AT IT AT A LATER
DATE.
BUT BECAUSE A WORKING IN GOOD
FAITH AND BOTH AGREED -- TO TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM -- WE THOUGHT
THOSE IMPORT TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING AND WE CAN CONTINUE.
TO LOOK AT IT AT A DIFFERENT
TIME BUT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS.
JUST VERY QUICKLY SO -- ARE
THERE ANY AUTOMOBILES OR LIMOS
THAT FIT THE DESCRIPTION OF THIS
BILL THAT CURRENTLY MEET THE
STANDARDS.
OF THE THERE AREN'T IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN DO THAT
THERE ARE SOME AND I HAVE
PICTURES OF THE BE HAPPY.
TO INTO THE COMMITTEE -- IN
COLORADO THERE ARE BUSES THAT DO
HAVE SEPARATE -- KIND OF
ISOLATED CABINS FOR THE DRIVERS
SHOULD AND SEALED OFF SO THAT
THERE IS NO PENETRATION OF THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING. TO
TO KIND OF COPY HERE -- BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THIRD PARTY ENGINEER DESIGNS AND
INSPECTS AND REALLY CAN CERTIFY.
THAT IT IS -- IT'S IT'S ONLY
ISOLATED SO ONCE SO THERE IT
WILL NOT BE WHO THEY WON'T BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE CANNABIS.
IN THE US UNTIL SUCH TIME ABOUT
STATE THAT'S IT THAT'S
DEFINITELY TRUE BUT THEY CAN'T
DO IT TODAY ACTUALLY SO THEY
DON'T KNOW AND UNDERSTAND WITH
THE PASSAGE WITH THE SENATE ALL
WOULD NOT BE APPROVED -- IT
WOULD NOT BE USED UNTIL -- THERE
IS THAT CERTIFICATION OF THAT
VEHICLE AND THAT IT IS SAFE.
TROUT.
I THANK YOU.
IT'S ONE TAKE A OF JUST A POINT
OF COURTESY AND AND WE HAVE A
LATE COMER TO I I BELIEVE EITHER
OPPOSE OR SUPPORT.
HOW DOES A COURTESY?
I THINK I WAS COMING FROM THE
BACK OF THE ROOM MISTER
PRITCHETT WERE WERE ONE OF THOSE
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
LOOKING.
TO GET TO THAT -- TOO POSITION
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE WE'VE BEEN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU BUT BASED OFF THE
NEGOTIATIONS WE HOPE TO GET.
THERE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE NOT
JUST FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
DRIVER BUT ALSO THAT SMOKING HAS
TO GO SOMEWHERE.
HOPEFULLY IS MORE THESE VEHICLES
GET CERTIFIED IN THE RIGHT WAY
AND FORCE THE RIGHT WAY THAT'LL
US WAGE THOSE CONCERTS ARE JUST
ONE WAY THAT AND THANK THE
SENATOR AND HIS STAFF FOR UP FOR
THE WORK.
ANY -- CONTINUING QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR --
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE WE NEED A FIRST OR SECOND.
WE HAVE A FIRST OR SECOND
APOLOGIZE MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WASHES DUPONT'S TO COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE FOR THE
WHOLE THAT.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BROWN NOT VOTING CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CAN LOOK IT UP.
CA.GOV I'D LOW.
LOW ON A PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING FOLKS OVER.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH [inaudible]
SO CALLED.
MEASURES ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR THANK YOU
PUBLIC THANK YOU.
I SEE MISTER WESLEY READY TO
PRESENT ON SB [inaudible]
TWO EIGHT ALREADY [inaudible]
THE BILL.
I HAD GUESTS SO.
THANK YOU AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B.
OUR I'M SORRY SB TO AVOID IT'S A
CONSUMER CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILL.
AIMED AT PREVENTING WROBEL CALL
SCAMS.
YOU KNOW WHEN I HEARD THAT BY.
202240% OF EVERY SINGLE CALL
MADE IN YOUR TELEPHONE.
IT'S GONNA BE A FAKE CALL.
A COMPUTER GENERATED CALL AIMED.
AT TAKING YOUR MONEY.
I SAID WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS THIS IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM. 40% OF EVERY SINGLE
CALL MADE ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
NOT ONLY THAT -- SCAM IN HAS
BECOME A NINE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY IN AMERICA
[inaudible] NINE HUNDRED I'M
SORRY THOSE NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
I HAD TO BE TO IT.
STILL NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
AND NORMALLY THIS MONEY COMES
FROM THE MOST VULNERABLE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY USUALLY IT'S
THE ELDERLY.
USUALLY IT'S DISABLED THESE
PEOPLE ARE TARGETED BY THIS THE
MASS GENERATION OF THESE CALLS.
THIS BILL [inaudible]
WOULD REQUIRE THAT A CALLER ID
SYSTEM BE PUT IN PLACE BY THE
TELECOMMUTE.
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES THIS
BILL SETS A JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINES FOR THAT TO BE
DONE -- THIS WOULD REQUIRE THAT
OUR CALLER AUTHENTICATION --
PROGRAM BE -- INSTALLED.
INTO EVERYBODY'S ACCOUNT SO THAT --
THESE CALLS ARE PREVENTED.
AND LARGELY I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE IT VERY VERY CLEAR.
THIS -- TARGETS SPOOFING.
IT DOES NOT EXPAND THE CPU SEES
AUTHORITY.
IT NARROWLY ALLOWS THE CPUC TO
WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST ILLEGAL
ROBO CALLERS.
SO MOSTLY THAT WOULD TAKE IT A
SHAPE IN THE FIFTH AND AND IN
THE WAY OF IDENTIFYING.
OR OR GATHER INFORMATION
GATHERING COMPLAINTS --
GATHERING INFORMATION.
BAND THAT COULD GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
ENFORCE THIS.
IT ALSO DOES NOT REQUIRE CALL
BLOCKING.
CALL BLOCKING THE IS NOT
SOMETHING THIS BILL LAST
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES TO
DO.
AND IT ALSO WOULD NOT RESULT IN
REAL CALLS BEING BLOCKED BECAUSE
THIS -- THIS IDENTIFIER SYSTEM
WHERE THIS TECHNOLOGY SIMPLY
LOOKS FOR COMPUTER GENERATED
CALLS.
DOES THE THE THAT -- ONLY THOSE
THAT DO NOT IMPLEMENT CALLER ID.
AUTHENTICATION SYSTEMS AND
USUALLY THOSE WOULD BE -- THE
THE ROBO CALLS.
THOSE THAT DO NOT -- COMPLETE
THAT WOULD BE A COMMITTEE LED A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW UNDER THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP RESTORE
COMPETE CONSUMERS CONFIDENCE IN
THEIR TELEPHONE.
IT WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE.
FAKE CALLS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR CITIES -- PULL OR EVEN THE
IRS.
WE'LL HAVE RECEIVE CALLS FROM.
OF SPOOFING CALLS THAT HAVE A I
ARRESTS CALL IDENTIFIER OR A THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO OR CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO OR CITY.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO GET PEOPLE TO
ANSWER THE PHONES.
SO THEY COULD SCAM THEM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS EFFORT TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
TREMENDOUS PROBLEM AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR WHAT IS IT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VINCENT LAY WITH THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE.
FOCUS ON RACIAL EQUITY IN
ENSURING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE FRAUD AND DECEPTIVE
CALLS STILL IT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AWAY.
OUR FATHERS NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FRAUD THE ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE ECONOMY IS.
NEARLY TEN BILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR.
AND THE PEOPLE MOST AFFECTED OUR
SENIORS -- BLACK IN THE NEXT
COMMUNITIES.
I YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW THE
SENATOR SAID SCAMMERS ARE POSING
AS THE IRS -- OR SOCIAL SECURITY
I GOT A CALL LAST WEEK --
TELLING ME MY SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER THAT WAS CANCELED AND A
CALL BACK AND THEY'RE DOING THIS
IS STILL ID'S FROM PEOPLE THEIR
IDENTITIES.
AND THEY ARE EVEN STEALING FOOD
BENEFITS FROM FOLKS BY POSING AS
A DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
YOU KNOW THIS TO BE KIND OF
THINGS UNDERMINE TRUST IN THE
PHONE SYSTEM BUT ALSO OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
SO WE MUST QUICKLY TAKE ACTION
TO STOP THIS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS -- WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ARE
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ -- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIAN ALSO
ON BEHALF OF TURN.
IN SUPPORT THE BILL AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
OTHERS BEEN A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS ISSUE IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
BUT FEDERAL LEVEL AND STATE
LEVEL.
AND REALLY WE'VE ARRIVED AT A
POINT WHERE THERE IS TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS AVAILABLE -- AND WITH
THIS BILL REALLY.
NO DOZEN WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
DOLLARS JUST SET THE TIME
CERTAIN -- THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
WILL BE USED TO HELP ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE -- AS BOTH THE AUTHOR
THE WITNESS STATED -- THIS
PROBLEM IS GROWING IT'S GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY AND IT'S NOT JUST
GROWN AND AS FAR AS NUMBER AND
VOLUME BUT IT'S GROWN IN THE
TYPE OF SCAMS THAT ARE OCCURRING.
I HEARD SOME OF THE EXAMPLES BUT
WE'VE ALSO HAD FOR EXAMPLE SAN
DIEGO -- WHERE THE NUMBER CAME
UP WAS IF IT WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THEN THE?
AND THEY'RE SAYING THAT THERE
WAS A WARRANT THAT WAS A THAT
WAS OUT AND IF YOU DIDN'T PAY --
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS FIVE
DOLLARS ON THE SPOT OVER THE
PHONE -- THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
ARREST THAT WOULD BE OCCURRING
SO THINGS LIKE THAT ARE GOING ON
OVER AND OVER AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED THERE'S SPOOFING OF
CITIES COUNTIES.
STATE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT SOME
THAT NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH THIS
BILL REALLY TAKES AN EVEN HANDED
APPROACH -- IN CALIFORNIA AND
GIVE SOME ASSURANCE AND
CONFIDENCE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
GOING TO BE USED -- BY JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S REALLY ALL
THIS BILL DOES WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY CANNOT SIT
AND WAIT AND HOPE THE TECHNOLOGY
IS GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS.
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
BILL AN OUNCE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
JAMES JACK ON BEHALF OF CAL TELL --
CAL TELL HAS HAD A A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION SINCE THE BILL
WAS HEARD AND TENDER PLACES
COMMITTEE -- OUR MEMBERS ARE
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROTOCOLS IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR --
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
SENATORS OFFICE TO ADDRESS ONE
REMAINING -- PORTION OF THE BILL --
WHEN THE BILL HOPEFULLY GETS
PRIVACY COMMITTEE AND WILL BE
OFFERING OUR FULL SUPPORT AT
THAT TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU?
HI TERRY DAIS SANDERS
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE FROM LADY OUR
OFFICE REPAIR ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TO IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WE GO TO A MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MIGHT MAKE SOME ROOM
FOR THEM PLEASE THANK YOU.
MR CARE MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO TO
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
CCT IS -- CURRENTLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
SENATOR HOPING TO GET TO A SOME
RESOLUTION.
BUT WE WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH -- IMPLEMENTING THE STERN
SHAKEN OR COMPARABLE TECHNOLOGY
TO BLOCK LOCAL CALLS -- WE AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING FOLKS THE CENTER
HAS SAID ANOTHER HAVE SAID THIS
IS THE SCOURGE OF THE OF THE
LAND RIGHT NOW BOTHERING PEOPLE
AND OUR CUSTOMERS GET UPSET.
SO WE HAVE ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED
WITH THE FCC AND FORTY STATE
ATTORNEY GENERALS AND TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A PROPER PROTOCOLS --
TO IMPLEMENT AT TO TO BLOCK
THESE CALLS AND SO -- WE
APPRECIATE -- AG PESETAS
INVOLVEMENT HE'S ONE OF THE
FORTY ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH THE FCC
RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'RE HOPING TO SEE PROGRESS
LAST THURSDAY THE FCC MADE SOME
ADDITIONAL -- REQUIREMENTS --
FOR COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS ONE OF THEM IS NOW WE
IN THE INTERIM BEFORE THIS
CHICKEN AND STIR A COMPARABLE
TECHNOLOGY IS ADOPTED WE HAVE TO
OFFER TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
APPS THAT WILL AUTOMATICALLY
BLOCK THESE CALLS THE DEFAULT
SITUATION IS CALLS ARE BLOCKED --
THE THEY WILL HAVE THIS APP
BETTER SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS WE
HAVE THIS APP THAT THEIR SERVICE.
WE HAVE TO PROPERLY INFORM THEM
THAT WE WERE PUTTING THEM ON
THIS PROGRAM AND THAT THE
DEFAULT IS IT'S BLOCK UNLESS YOU
ARE YOU'RE IN THE PROGRAM.
AND YOU HAVE TO OPT OUT SO THE
CUSTOMERS HAVE DROPPED OUT.
THIS JUST HAPPENS OVER TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT THAT
SO WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS.
WITH WITH SHAKEN AND STIR WITH%
SB TO AWAIT.
THE DATE CERTAIN IS NOT AN ISSUE
FOR US AND SO WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON IN THIS
AS WELL -- WE DO HAVE SOME KIND
OF PROCEDURAL CONCERNS AT THIS
POINT.
AND ONE OF THEM IS WITH THE
LIABILITY PROTECTION --
CERTAINLY NOW WITH THE FCC
MAKING ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT -- CUSTOMERS BE
AUTOMATICALLY PUT INTO A PROGRAM
TO BLOCK ROBOCALLS.
WE LIKE TO SEE IS THAT -- IN THE
EVENT THAT IN GOOD FAITH THAT IF
WE WERE TO BLOCK A CALL THAT WAS
A CRITICAL EMERGENCY ALERT --
AND BEST INTENTION IS NOT TO DO
THAT AND NOT TO BLOCK IT BUT
AGAIN THIS IS BRAND NEW PRO --
BRANDS SOFTWARE THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT
DONE SO WE'RE WORKING ON IT WE
HOPE THAT WERE BETA TESTING IT
RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE EIGHTEEN
TEASE BETA TESTING.
COMCAST IS BETA TESTING THAT SO
IT'S NOT COMPLETE SO WE HAVE
EVERY INTENTION OF COMPLYING
WITH THIS REQUIREMENT BY THE END
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
BUT YOU KNOW BETTER INTENTIONS --
WE WE JUST HOPE THAT WE DO COULD
GET TO COMPLETE THAT SO WITH
SOME SORT OF LIABILITY
PROTECTION THAT WOULD BE
CRITICAL FOR US.
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO THE PC
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND I HEAR
THE CENTER SAY THAT THERE IS NO
NEW OBLIGATIONS -- GIVEN TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN THIS
PROVISION.
BUT AS YOU READ -- SUBSECTION
SEE ONE AND SEE TO I MEAN
THERE'S THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT THAT SECTION.
TWO TWO SEVEN OF TITLE FORTY
SEVEN IS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT IT'S
NOT ABOUT US ADOPTING
REGULATIONS US DOING SOMETHING
IT'S ABOUT.
GOING AFTER THE BAD WROBEL
CALLERS THAT'S WHAT SECTION --
TWO TWO SEVEN SAYS.
SO THE AG HAS TO TAKE THESE BAD
ACTORS INTO FEDERAL COURT IT'S
NOT A STATE COURT YOU HAVE TO GO
TO FEDERAL COURT.
MOST RUBBER CALLERS ARE NOT IN
STATE A MOST OF THEM QUITE A FEW
OF THEM ARE OVERSEAS.
SO THIS IS A VERY COMPLICATED
MATTER OF SUMMER USING
COMPLICATED SOFTWARE A
COMPLICATED ENFORCEMENT MEASURE --
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT
THE P. UC'S INVOLVEMENT AND
TRYING. TO GATHER THE PROPER
INFORMATION IS PROBABLY NOT BEST
SUITED FOR THEM - MISTER CHAIR
YOU HAVE TODAY UNDER CURRENT LAW
SEVEN TEN THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE TO YOU -- COMPLAINTS
ABOUT WHAT SERVICE BY THAT
REQUIREMENTS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
SEVEN YEARS THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
REPORT THAT TO YOU ANNUALLY AT
YOUR HEARINGS YOUR ANNUAL
HEARING AND ANNUALLY IN A REPORT.
AND AS FAR AS I CAN RECALL NOT
ONCE HAVE THEY PROVIDE YOU ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
COMPLAINTS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE QUITE
COMPLAINTS BECAUSE WHEN THE PEWS
HE WILL GET ONE THEY WILL REFER
THEM TO US AND WE WILL RESOLVE
THOSE ARE OUR TICKETS THAT WE
WILL RESOLVE.
BUT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
THEY'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE
AND THEY REALLY HAVEN'T SO AND
THAT WAS JUST REFERRING
COMPLAINTS CITY GIVEN YOUR FROM
ABOUT COMPLAINTS NOW IF YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE SOMETHING AS COOL.
AS COMPLICATED IN CRITICAL AS
MOBILE KHôNG FORSMAN ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL -- WE WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY THAT THAT IT'S
NOT A ROLE PROP PROPER FOR THEM
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
PRINT WITHOUT.
A PIECE OF THE BILL AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE THE COMMISSION -- BUT
AGAIN WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
BLOCKING ROBO CALLS OUR
CUSTOMERS COMPLAIN JUST AS MUCH
AS YOUR CONSTITUENTS COMPLAIN
SENATOR SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
OUR BASS.
WITH THAT -- I WILL.
READ MISTER HOUSE THEY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON FOR
CTIA THE WIRELESS ASSOCIATION.
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE NEW WITH THAT THE THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS -- AN
ADULT IT WASN'T THE SUGGESTION
OF THE OF THE SENATOR BUT YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
SUGGESTION BY THE WITNESSES IS
THAT SOMEHOW OR OTHER.
WE'RE NOT DOING WHAT WE OUGHT TO
BE DOING ON THIS AND THAT'S JUST
A THAT'S NOT A FACT -- WE HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
FCC ON THE SO CALLED CHICKEN
STIR PROTOCOLS TO HER BERNIE
DESCRIBED THE REASON ACTION ON
BEHALF OF THE FCC WHICH HAS BEEN
VERY ACTIVE IN THIS AREA.
OF CONGRESS IS ALSO LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE -- OUR CONCERN IS
HAVING A DIFFERENT ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM AT THE STATE LEVEL
VERSUS THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
COULD BE COULD BE CONCERNING AND
EVEN THOUGH WE ALL HATE ROBO
CALLS -- AND BOOK TALK TO THE
THE SENATOR AND STAFF ABOUT THIS
WE'RE NOT THE BAD GUYS IN THIS
YOU KNOW THERE ARE.
A LOT OF BAD GUYS WORKING VERY
HARD TO PREVENT THE BAD GUYS
FROM FROM DOING THIS.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR ON IT MAYBE -- WORKING
OUT SOME OF THE ISSUES -- THAT
BERNIE HAS -- HAS HAS INDICATED
WE WOULD -- WE WOULD SUPPORT
THAT -- BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS
THAT WE'RE DOING ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WE CAN.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS MAKE THIS
HAPPEN -- WE WANT IT TO HAPPEN
AS AS AS MUCH AS EVERYBODY ELSE --
ONE OF THE THINGS THE COMMITTEE
SHOULD ALSO KNOW AS BERNIE
ALLUDED.
TO MANY ROBO CALLS ARE ARE --
INTENTIONAL AND ARE ARE ARE
BENEFICIAL YOU GET A COFFEE OR
PHARMACY GET A CALL FROM THE
SCHOOL -- YOU GET EMERGENCY
ALERT CALLS WE HAVE TO BE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT THROWING OUT THE
BABY WITH THE BATH WATER AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN TARGET
THESE -- IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY --
SO WITH THAT BUT MANY CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE SENATOR I'M AND
HIS STAFF ON THIS ISSUE BUT FOR
NOW WE WE WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OTHER
THAT YOU'RE AT THE PRESENT
ANOTHER BILL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIC
TOMORROW HERE BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED ALSO OPPOSE.
CAME TO ME TRêN BAFFERT
TECHNION ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SIMILAR PATTERSON.
I WANT TO JUST IT UP EXPLORE
COUPLES I I HAVE A LONG HISTORY
WITH.
THE FCC BROADCAST OWNER OPERATOR
STAYS.
THE CONCERN I HAVE IS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT THE THAT THIS
IS A INTERNATIONAL ISSUE AS WELL
DOES OF STE.
CROSS UNITED STATES -- SO IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THE BEST PLACE
FOR THIS.
IS THAT THE FCC AND WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S -- MY CONCERN
IS THAT INSERTING.
ARE THE P. YOU SEE INTO THIS I
ACTUALLY THINK IS GOING TO WORK
AGAINST THE INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO.
AGAIN AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
UTILITY AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
THE P. YOU SEE IN MY JUDGMENT.
REALLY DOES NOT EXECUTED --
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL.
IN ANY OF THESE AREAS AND
PARTICULARLY I THINK IN THE
INTERNET SPACE THIS REALLY IS AN
AREA WHERE IT OUGHT.
TO IT REALLY OUGHT TO BE OUT
OUTSIDE OF THEIR OF THEIR
PURVIEW -- SO.
WHAT IS IT?
IN ADDITION TO OUR APART FROM
WHAT THE FCC IS DOING.
AND WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
SERRA.
IS DOING AND WHAT WOULD YOU
CONSIDER ELIMINATING THE P. YOU
SEE AND THEN.
FOLLOW UP TO THAT WOULD BE.
EXPLAIN THE NECESSITY FOR THE
BILL.
IF WE'VE GOT THE FCC AND THAT'S
OUR TWENTY GENERAL ENGAGED IN
THIS TO THE DEGREE THAT THEY ARE.
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE ENGAGED
ISN'T.
THE IT'S PART OF THE SOLUTION
THEY HAVEN'T COME TO A SOLUTION
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR A NATION
WIDE SOLUTION.
THAT HE IS STILL FAR FROM US
[inaudible]
SO.
I THINK CALIFORNIA COULDN'T PAVE
THE WAY TOWARD A SOLUTION I
THINK WE HAVE A VERY -- THOROUGH
SOLUTION -- THE P. YOU SEE IS
NOT THE LEADER.
IN IN SOLVING THIS PROBLEM.
NOT EVEN CLOSE THEY ARE ONLY A
VERY.
SMALL SMALL PART OF THE BILL IN
FACT I DON'T SEE HOW THEM EVEN
BEING PART OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
HERTZ ENFORCEMENT IN ANY WAY A
TO GIVE YOU AN ANALOGY.
IF MY CHILD WAS KIDNAPPED.
AND I WENT.
TO THE FBI IN THE POLICE AND
THEY SAID WEL.
THIS IS YOU KNOW I I I'M NOT
ALLOWED BY LAW. TO TO GET
INVOLVED THIS IS A LOCAL MATTER.
I I AS A PARENT I WOULD WANT
EVERY RESOURCE I WOULD WANT THE
FBI THE SHERIFF'S THE POLICE
EVERYONE TO DO AN ALL OUT SEARCH
FOR MY CHILD.
WHAT IT WHAT IT PUTTING MORE
RESOURCES INTO SOLVING A PROBLEM
BE BETTER AT SOLVING THAT
PROBLEM?
SO THE ROLE THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO THE PC IS A VERY SMALL ROLE
IT'S A SUPPORTING ROLE.
AND IT'S WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
ANYWHERE THE THE APPEAL SEE.
HAS ANY ABILITY TO PROVIDE
[inaudible]
INFORMATION.
SOME INFORMATION COULD BE
CRITICAL TO APPREHENDING.
SOMEBODY THAT'S DOING SOMETHING
WRONG OR FIGURING OUT WHAT WHAT
IS THE PROBLEM WHY ARE THESE
CALLS PERSISTING.
IF CALIFORNIA HAS A LAW ON WE
HAVE A TECHNOLOGY THE PC COULD
BE VERY HELPFUL.
AND WE'VE REACHED OUT TO PAY YOU
SEE TO FIND WHAT THAT ROLE COULD
BE AND WE'VE ACTUALLY GONE TO
DIFFERENT APARTMENTS TO ASK WHAT
THEIR ROLE COULD BE.
AND WE'VE GONE -- WE'VE TALKED
TO THE ATTORNEYS TURNING
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND WE SAID
WHAT WHAT WOULD HOW COULD WE
HELP YOU ENSURE THAT YOU HAVE
SUCCESS.
GENERALLY PEOPLE WANT.
SUPPORT PEOPLE WANT MORE
RESOURCES AND PEOPLE WANT ACCESS
TO INFORMATION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL.
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT EMPOWERS
A P. YOU SEE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM DOES NOT.
A BILL THAT REQUIRES A P. YOU
SEE THAT SOLVES A PROBLEM IT
DOESN'T MAKE THE P. YOU SEE.
THE THE THE LEADER IN SOLVING
THIS PROBLEM IT IS SIMPLY
PROVIDING A SUPPORTING ROLE TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND TO THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS WHO ALSO HAVE.
A RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PROVIDING THE SERVICE
THAT YOU WE ARE ALL PAID -- FOR
HAS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
REQUESTED THIS LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
NO.
REQUESTED I COULDN'T SAY THAT HE
REQUESTED IT.
THIS IS A LEGISLATION THAT WAS
DEVELOPED WITH THAT MY OFFICE
AND WE HAVE CONSULTED DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND DIFFERENT CONSUMER
GROUPS.
WE HAVE GONE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SO I HOPE THAT
TODAY.
AND THE TESTIMONY THE HEARING
TODAY'S KIND OF INDICATIVE OF
WHO.
HIS IS AT THE TABLE WHO WHO HAS
REVIEWED THIS BILL WHO HAS SEEN --
THAT THIS BILL COULD BE USEFUL
OR HELPFUL AND AND WHEN IT COMES
TO THE INDUSTRY I UNDERSTAND.
THEIR JOB IS YEAH IS IS IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE TO REDUCE
LIABILITY TO REDUCE.
A GOVERNMENT REGULATION TO
LIMóN.
EIGHT ARE OUR YOU KNOW US WANTED
TO COME IN AND SAY WE NEED YOU
TO DO THIS I UNDERSTAND THAT I
I'M NOT CRITICAL.
OF THE INDUSTRY AND I I HAVE TO
SAY THE INDUSTRY'S BEEN WORKING
VERY WELL.
WITH MY OFFICE AND WE'VE MET ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS AND I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THEIR CONCERNS.
AND I'M AND THEY RAISE SOME
ISSUES.
THAT DESERVE OUR ATTENTION.
AND I'M LISTENING TO THEM AND
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
SOLVE THEIR PROBLEM.
WITHOUT MAKING THIS BILL.
ANOTHER A DO NOTHING BILL.
IT BEHOOVES US ALL THIS IS OUR
JOB THIS IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE WE SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
THIS IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
AND I WANT TO SOLVE THEIR
PROBLEMS WELL THIS IS
SOMETHING'S JUST.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T DO
THINGS.
REQUIRE SOMETHING WITHOUT AN
OFFRAMP THE SAME THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF THE AMENDMENT TO
REQUEST SEEN THEIR AMENDMENTS IT
IS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED MAKE THE
BILL.
A NOTHING BILL AND I AND I KNOW.
I YOU KNOW THEY HAVE WE WE HAVE
KICKED AROUND SOME IDEAS AND AND
ON YOU KNOW WHAT I AT WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO GET THEIR OWN
LANGUAGE BUT WE MAY BE ABLE TO
GET THERE.
IN A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL WE
MAY BE ABLE TO GET THERE IN SOME
INTENT LANGUAGE BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE P. YOU SEE TAKE YOU WANTING
A CHOOSING.
TO MAYBE NOT IGNORING THE
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER THIS BILL
IN CHOOSING TO DO SOMETHING ELSE
IT.
LET WHAT IT WOULD NOT BE CORRECT
THEY WOULD BE WRONG IN DOING
THAT UNDER THIS BILL THE BILL I
WHEN I LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE ALL
THIS LANGUAGE REQUIRES HIM TO DO.
IS TO PUT EMPLOYMENT A COLOR I'D
AUTHENTICATION SYSTEM IT'S ALL
IT DOES.
IT DOESN'T SAY THAT IT HAS TO
WORK IT DOESN'T SAY THAT OUR
HOUSE.
TO BLOCK EVERY SINGLE CALL IT OR
EVERY SINGLE OF SPOOFING CALL --
THE THE BILL BILL IS PRETTY
SIMPLE [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THE THE DOES THE BILL IN YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF IT.
UP PROVIDE PROTECTION -- FOR
LIABILITY WHEN SOMETHING SLIPS
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND IT'S
UNINTENTIONAL.
OR IS THIS IS JUST THROWING THEM
ALL IN A BASKET THAT SAYS IF YOU
MESS UP ONCE.
YOUR GUILTY AGAIN YOU COULD
ARGUE THAT OF EVERY BILL AND
EVERY ABSENCE OF A BILL.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE LAWS
THAT ARE CREATED BY THE
JUDICIARY WHEN WE FAIL TO
CONNECT THEM.
AND THERE ARE LAWSUITS THAT ARE
TRIGGERED.
BY AN ABSENCE OF A LAW AS MUCH
AS THEY ARE BY THE EXISTENCE OF
A LOST SOUL.
THE WAY I TRIED TO REDUCE THAT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN THE WAY
WE WROTE THIS BILL BUT ALSO IN
THE WAY THAT.
IT REQUIRES.
THAT THE TICKET
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES DO
THAT SO.
IT REQUIRES THEM TO DO SOMETHING.
AND IF THEY DON'T DO THAT.
THIS BILL MUCH FRONT END IN ONE
FILE FOLLOW AT THAT THE QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO LEGITIMATE ROBO
CALLS YEAH -- TO ME.
IF THE ARMS SIGN A LEGITIMATE
ROBO CALL.
WELL THAT THE EXAMPLES WERE
GIVEN HERE YOUR PHARMACIST --
BECAUSE YOU SAYS THAT YOU HAVE
THAT DOES THAT IT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT COMPUTER GENERATED FOR
THAT DAY ARE COMPUTER GENERATED
NO NO I I UNDERSTAND BUT THESE
ARE CALLS -- THAT ARE ARE.
ARE GENERATED BY.
USING A FAKE ID USE IN OF A
MISLEADING.
OF GEN NADER.
NOW IF OF PHARMACISTS MAKES A
CALL FROM HIS OFFICE OR FROM YOU
HIRES A SERVICE.
A LEGITIMATE BUSINESS SERVICE
THIS DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THOSE
CALLS. TO A COMING THROUGH
SOMETHING THAT COMES THROUGH THE
THAT LOOKS LIKE A REBEL CALL IS
THAT
TECHNOLOGY SUFFICIENT. TO BE
ABLE TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
THE TWO YES BECAUSE IF IT I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE -- IT'S
SIMILAR.
IF YOU EVER GONE TO A WEB PAGE
OR SOMETHING AND IT REQUIRES YOU
TO THE TO CONFIRM THAT YOU'RE A
PERSON.
AND IT GIVES YOU A LITTLE LINE
IT SAYS.
RIGHT WHAT THIS READ TODAY HAS A
CURSIVE.
IT'LL READ CAT IN CURSIVE.
AND YOU PUT YOUR PUNCH AND CA T.
AND AND YOU PRESS CENTER.
THAT IS AN AUTHENTICATION SYSTEM
IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
SO THE CALL IS BEING GENERATED
BY A COMPUTER COMPUTER CAN.
INTERPRET THAT HE COULD
INTERPRET THE CURSIVE WORD FOR
CATS OR WHAT EVER --
AUTHENTICATION IMPEDIMENT IS PUT
BEFORE.
THE THE COMPUTER SYSTEM THAT IS
IN THE AREA OF WHAT WERE WORK
WE'RE TRYING TO THE WHAT THE
TECHNOLOGY WOULD -- BE SIMILAR.
TO DOES THAT TECHNOLOGY EXIST
PRESIDENT PASSING TO WISH TO
SUMMARIZE YOUR DATA ONE FINAL
YESTERDAY YES OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COULD BE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
TINO DIGITAL QUESTIONS ARE
COMMON SENATE OFFICE OF JEWISH
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MEMBERS --
SIMPLICES OF IMPORTANT PROBLEM.
A BIG PROBLEM AND I HOPE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT AND SALAS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND JUST AS A REMINDER
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION IS A TO
PASS. TO CONSECUTIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE.
BUT A WHOLE THAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO [inaudible]
RONO CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
LOW ON AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH.
THE BILL HAS A SIX VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A IT'S
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
NOW I KNOW THAT WAS SERGEANTS
ARE CALLING FOR OUR FINAL AUTHOR
AND THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB SIX SEVENTY BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME -- PERHAPS
WE CAN JUST GO THROUGH THE ROLE
AGAIN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND
THIS IS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HELD THE FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS.
PLEASE LET THE CALL [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
BUT THE WHOLE Và.
I HOPE THAT NO.
I'D NUMBER TWO SB [inaudible]
SIX TWO FIVE CERVANTES
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SEVEN TO ONE SEVEN
TO ONE THAT MEASURE IS OUT SO
AGAIN WE'RE JUST WAITING ON OUR
FINAL.
AUTHOR 2% WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB SIX SEVENTY BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
IF YOU'RE READY -- FOR OUR FINAL
BILL FOR THIS HEARING TODAY.
HI THIS IS FOR MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS SB SIX
SEVENTY BY.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THE CLERK WILL SAVE SEVEN
NIELSEN UP WAS ALSO JOINING US
AT TO BOTH SENATORS SAID THERE
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY.
BEHALF OF CENTER NIELSEN AYE AND
MYSELF WE WANT TO SAY HOW GREAT
WE ARE TO YOUR IN YOUR
COMMITTEES -- ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL WILL BE VERY QUICK SINCE
THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
WANT TO SAY GRATEFUL IN THE
WORKS WITH LIKE TO BE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
HE'S A PARTNER IN ALL THIS
CENTER NIELSEN.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS SB SIX
SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE CALLOW YES
TO SET THRESHOLDS THROUGH A
MARTIN C. REGULATIONS.
THE REGULATIONS -- WOULD FOCUS
ON TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES
THAT IMPACT NINE ONE ONE CALL
CENTERS AND I WOMAN SERVICE AND
EMERGENCY OVERT CAPABILITIES
SPECIFICALLY WHEN THEY GO DOWN.
WHAT WOULD END UP HAPPENING IN
SHOULD BE HAPPENING NOW BUT
SECONDLY IT DOESN'T -- IS THAT
THE TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANY
WOULD WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH
CALLAWAY YES PROVIDE THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
OUTAGE.
THE PRODUCT THE ESTIMATED TIME
TO RESTORE THE OUTAGE AND A
CONTACT PERSON THAT CALLAWAY IS
CAN REACH. FOR FURTHER UPDATES
SO WE'RE GETTING REAL TIME
UPDATES YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
THE FIRE CHIEF TODAY ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO OUR PARTNER IN ALL
THIS CENTER NIELSEN.
ALL OF THE SYSTEMS REQUIRE A LOT
OF INNER CONNECTIVE ITTY.
ANY POINT OF FAILURE.
AND DISASTERS CAN HAPPEN.
NOW WE ALWAYS HAVE DISASTERS BUT
SOME OF US HAVE BEEN RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF SOME COLOSSAL
HISTORIC ONCE.
AND WE'VE SEEN HOW COMMUNICATION
DIFFICULTIES.
CAN COST LIVES.
WE HAD A SCHOOL SHOOTING
INCIDENT HAPPENED. TO HIM A
COUNTY.
AND WE DID NOT HAVE.
ACCESS TO THAT SCHOOL.
THERE WAS NO.
COMMUNICATION.
RESPONSE TOOK A LOT LONGER.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT
PROVIDING BETTER OPTIONS FOR OUR
CITIZENS. TO CRY OUT FOR HELP.
AND RECEIVE THAT HELP IT'S A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND OF COURSE WITH THIS THIS
AUTHOR.
WE'RE GOOD COMPANIONS TOGETHER
IN THE RURAL AREAS.
WE PARTICULARLY HAVE UNDERSTOOD
THE CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION AS CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
THE BILL.
HAS BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLES -- TO THE WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL WILL BE VERY QUICK GREAT.
HI.
MORNING SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TONY GOES ON THE FIRE CHIEF FOR
THE CITY SANTA ROSA WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
YOU KNOW WE HAD A FIRE IT WAS
THE TUBS FIRE THE IMPACT OUR
COMMUNITY ON JUST GIVE ME A REAL
QUICK -- EVERYONE'S COMPARE
HANLEY VERSUS TUBBS FAMILY TOOK
FOUR DAYS TO GET TO US THE TUB
STARTED ANOTHER KIND OF TOOK
FOUR HOURS WE LOST ALL
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
I WOULD JUST WAS NOT THERE THIS
IS GOING TO HELP WITH ALL THAT
AND ALERTING OUR FOLKS MOVING
FORWARD TO SOME VERY IMPORTANT.
PURPOSE THANK YOU.
QUESTION MEMBERS CORSO'S LOW
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION HAPPY
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME AND THE
MULTIPLE MOTIONS OF THE SECONDS
I WILL JUST SAY TIMELY
NOTIFICATION OF OUTAGES CRUCIAL.
KNOWING THE STATUS OF EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION CAPABILITY --
HELPS PREPARE FOR ACTION AND
HELPS DIRECT RESOURCES
APPROPRIATELY SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME INFLATON
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY
VELMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS STRONG SUPPORT.
RESEARCHER CHRIS MY KAYLEE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BILLS INDUSTRY
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
YES SANDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
FORMALLY THE OFFICER REPAIR
ADVOCATES -- IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVENTY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON RUSSELL NOVAK
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS BILL DIVINE WITH
EIGHTEEN T. WITH THE CHANGES WE
AGREED TO THIS MORNING OR
COMFORTABLE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
RUN EVERY TO GO HERE ON BEHALF
OF LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
BERNIE ROSCOE WHAT COMPANY CABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT OF AMENDED JUST VERY
BRIEFLY JUST A COUPLE MEMBERS
THAT WE WERE STILL LOOKING --
FOR ONE IS -- WE LOVE THAT THE
APPROACH IS THAT WE CAN USE IN
APA PROCESS TO DEVELOP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS FOR PROPER
NOTIFICATION -- THERE ARE SOME
LANCASTER ABOUT EMERGENCY --
RULES TO GO TO PLACE AND THAT'S
NOT A PROBLEM BECAUSE THAT'S
PART OF THE APA PROCESS.
THERE IS AN EXEMPTION IN THE
BILL RIGHT NOW AND A PART OF
THOSE EMERGENCY RULES ARE IN YOU
TOP THOSE REGULATIONS YOUR
EXEMPTION OURSELVES FOR
EXEMPTING OH YES FROM.
COMPLYING WITH KEY ELEMENTS OF
THE APA PROCESS -- WE'RE WE'RE
NOT SURE THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE --
EXEMPTION TO HALF OF WHY WE
WOULD NOTE THAT IS BECAUSE SINCE
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH -- YES ON
ESTABLISHING MO USED FOR SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT OUTAGES AND SO
DOES MO USE HAVE NOT BEEN
APPROVED HAVE BEEN PENDING AT
THE AT YES.
SINCE OCTOBER SO THAT IS ONE
ISSUE THAT WE WERE STILL HOPING
TO RESOLVE -- THE SECOND ISSUE
IS SIXTY MINUTES AND YOU CAN CUT
ME SHORT -- WE WERE HOPING FOR
ONE TWENTY BUT THE REASON WHY WE
ASK FOR A BIT MORE TIME IS THAT.%
WE NOT ONLY NEED TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN HOUR'S BUT WE HAVE TO
VERIFY WHAT THAT AVERAGES.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO GIVE
YOU INFORMATION THAT IS USEFUL
ABOUT A SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
IF WE JUST HAVE TO COMPLY VERY
QUICKLY WE MAY NOT GIVE YOU THE
PROPER INFORMATION YOU NEED.
THANK YOU WHICH IS OUR MIND
EVERYBODY NAME AND MEMORIZATION
POSITIONALLY [inaudible]
OKAY -- CARLSON -- FOR THE CJ
THE WILD DISSOCIATION.
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR --
PRECIADO IT COUPLE MORE TWEAKS A
SIMILAR TO THE ONES BERNIE HAD
MENTIONED A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WE TALK TO YOUR STAFF ABOUT AND
AND I'M A COP AND WE CAN GET
THERE SO.
THAT'S WORTH AMENDED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JAMES TRACK ON
BEHALF OF CAL TELL -- WILL ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF CCPA AND CTI
THANK YOU.
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES PLEASE.
SORRY MR CHAIRMAN SORRY WAY TO
THE PARTY FALCONS OFFICE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS AND SUPPORT.
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
A SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THREE IS MY
REMOVING FOURTH EMERGENCY RACE
JUST LIKE WE DID WITH THE VERY
SIMILAR BILL THIS YEAR IS TO GET
THEM IMPLEMENTED PRIOR TO NEXT
FIRE SEASON.
AS A IT IS ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO
BE ABLE TO DO SO.
WE BELIEVE THAT SIXTY MINUTES IS
A REASONABLE APPROACH WITHIN ONE
HOUR OF DISCOVERY OF THE OUTAGE
I AND WE DO HAVE THE WERE
DISCOVERED IN THERE SO WHEN IT'S
DISCOVERED IN THAT CLOCK STARTS
TICKING.
VERSUS A HUNDRED TWENTY WHICH IS
TWO HOURS WHICH CANDIDATE WOULD
BE TOO LATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
SITUATION OF PARADISE.
WHAT EFFECT ASTRONOMICAL?
WE SHOULD I VOTE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU WE NEED A FIRST AND
SECOND.
HI MAN SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I HAVE BEEN A WHOLE
THAT.
WHOLE THAT I BONTA BONTA MY BRO.
CERVANTES CERVANTES ON MY
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CAN LONGER DUFF CAM
LIKE A DOVE I'D LOVE.
SO I KANSEN.
PATTERSON HI COOK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
ROD REDESIGN. ELEVEN TO SEVEN
MATCHES LEVEL ZERO MEASURES OUT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE ONE MEASURE
ON CALL ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TO
AWAIT [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I TEND TO TURN MEASURES.
TENDED TO MEASURES OUT.
HEY LET'S DO ADD ONS FOR THE
SAKE OF THOSE WHO NEED TO LEAVE --
SB [inaudible]
SIXTY FIVE MA'AM SECRETARY
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE NO [inaudible]
CERVANTES. SIXTY FIVE OH SOMEONE
OUGHT NOT VOTER HILL BILL.
I WANT TO GARCIA.
SOME TO MEASURES OUT. SEVEN TWO
MEASURES OUT.
NOW GET OUT ON THE SB SIX
SEVENTY THAT WOULD BE THE
MCGUIRE BILL [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
BECAUSE WE KEEP THE ROLE OPEN UP.
FOR ADD ONS FOR THE NEXT TWO
MINUTES.
SORT OF LIKE THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU FOR VISITING YEAH.
YEAH.
RIGHT NOW YEAH.
A LOT [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH I TOLD HIM.
YEAH I GET THE HAPPENED WHEN WE
CREATED YEAH BUT THE ONE YEAH
[inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
LEGAL [inaudible]
YEAH -- THEY DRIVE NOW.
THE BILL CAME ALONG WITH NOW WE
GOT A COUPLE [inaudible] FOR
COFFEE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
VOTE CHANGE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB SIX TWO FIVE SAMANTA IS FOR
NOT VOTING CERVANTES.
CERVANTES NOW FOR NOT VOTING TO
NOW.
OKAY THE WORK WILL TAKE A LOOK
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
DRIVER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH BUT WE DON'T HAVE.
TO YEAH
.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DISPENSED
WITH AND CNC COMMITTEE WILL
ADJOURN